I bought this Honda Civic 2014 EX with
only one key here and I I'll show you
this a good working key because I have
it here and I
can turn it on and ignition on and it
works I have here another one that I
bought that it doesn't work so if I take
this one out that's out of the car I
just put it around
there and I just keep this in when I try
to turn it on it complains it
says to start hold remote near so this
one doesn't work right now if I bring
the other one back
in it should work
now yeah it doesn't complain so I have
this autel and let let me show you
you the
mk808 K BT Bluetooth so I have it here
with me so I connected the mini VCI here
on the OBD board
yep so with the vehicle on and the VCI
MINI
Connected let's go into the tool
Diagnostics Honda
system
selection if I select USA for some
reason it doesn't show the
2014 so I'm going to have to use with
the go with the
general and this is what I would have Ed
you'll see it in a
second yeah 2014
cic
yes it was hot
[Music]
functions in
moys yes it is the one push start
here you have to go through a lot of uh
menus there I think it only
one
culus now I think it says registration
or something like that
yeah
registration keyless access
remotes so we're going to add
one and be careful and read everything
pretty much here we have done all these
things add keyless remote we're in that
step so now from here on we have to pay
attention to what it
says so follow on the screen so when
you're finished turn on the ignition
switch to off okay let's go
so it must be one register keyless
remote which is the one that we already
have
now uh the keyless remote that is
capable of starting the engine must be
in the vehicle right now it is and I
also have the other one that I want to
configure in the vehicle I think at one
point I have to take it out of the car
the ignition must be switched to on
which is right now using the keyless
remote okay let let's go and it's
important also ensure the following to
reduce noise as much as possible during
keyless remote rest stration turn off
all the electrical devices so I turn off
the
radio um any dash cam that you may have
any Chargers anything like that uh turn
off all electrical devices navigation on
your system separate on the diagnostic
tool which is what we're looking right
now from the keyless remote as much as
possible so I'm going to actually put it
maybe let it here there
um close all doors windows and sound
roofs yep it is and we can lock
them I can lock Jus is I don't
know yep my windows were down because
I'm it's h in
here okay this is a good sign
let's take one original keyless access
remote into the vehicle right now it is
remove all other keyless access remotes
from the vehicle so here's the good one
and here's the bad the one that I want
to
configure let's close
everything do not insert the keyless
access remote
vehicle um access remote slot is there's
no slot here press the okay
button turn the ignition switch on
and good way is to do it like
this just in case to be close for the
immobilizer to be
red okay most likely what it's doing now
it's reading this key that is working
completely take all the original keyless
access remotes out out of the vehicle
remaining time 94 seconds all right now
I'm going to take it
out here it goes the good
one now it's complaining of
course press okay to
continue
there only take one keyless access
remote into a vehicle
the new one let's put the new
one in here okay so I BR in the new key
into the car I pressed okay and it said
key register successfully so I only have
the the old the new key inside that I
want to configure and it says now turn
it off so I'm going to turn it off like
this
boom now it says turning on by using the
no ignition whatever that is but try to
do this with a key super close one
two now let's
see are both keyless imobilizer lights
to turn off yeah I don't see any lights
that says complains that this is not a a
u yeah I don't see any one any place
that says this is not a good key so
we're going to press yes
yep completed okay so let's try with
this key to start the car I'm pressing
the the brake right now well it says
turn it off wait turn it off first so
let's follow this thing I almost forgot
to follow it so turn it
on I only have the new key in it's done
so now I'm going to try to start it I'm
pressing the the brake
oh yeah oh yeah baby it works so I'm
going to turn it off and I'm going to
try
this
yeah so this is the new one I'm going to
leave the new one here let's bring the
old
one and leave the new one
out so this the old one yeah it works
and yeah I can start the car perfect
we did it awesome so if you like this
video please uh share like it and um and
subscribe because it's going to help me
on doing more videos like this one thank
you very much